we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p and in this
voicemail there's a question asked about
is someone coming up to you without a
mask an attack in a sense and if you are
in a stand-your-ground state could you
shoot such a person take a listen to
this yes on in hawaii i'm really curious
about those states that have the Stand
Your Ground laws so if you're outside
and somebody and you're in a mask and
somebody comes up to you that's not
wearing a mask why not just shooter
that's just my questions my thought
today thank you yeah listen I understand
the idea the idea is we've got a
contagious disease it's spreading
virally because it is a virus and people
should be protecting it themselves and
each other by wearing masks if someone
comes up with you up to you with no mask
if they COFF on you that potentially
puts your life in danger in the same way
than if they came up holding a gun and
pointing it at you I get the idea I
don't believe that even in States would
stand your ground you would get away
with shooting someone who is coming up
to you without a mask I don't recommend
you do it if you really have questions
about it consult law enforcement and a
lawyer but it sounds like a very very
bad idea I understand the sentiment I
understand the idea but it is not
something that I would imagine anyone is
going to get away with on today's bonus
show we will talk about Iran reportedly
launching its first military satellite
as Donald Trump continues to make
threats we will talk about Mitch
McConnell saying I wouldn't count on any
further coronavirus aid because of the
debt and we will talk about a police
department testing pandemic drones which
could sense fevers and coughing fevers
and coughing all of those stories on
today's bonus show don't miss it become
a member at join pakman.com and you will
get instant access